[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie mille Sono contentissima di
essere qui di portare un pezzo di me e
un pezzo di quella ragazzina di 17 anni
perché ho iniziato a 17 anni a 17 anni
non si sa niente di Balance bilancio Non
che a 20 se ne capisca qualcosa Eh ho
fatto qualche settimana fa l'esame di
bilancio di nuovo e non l'ho passato ci
riproviamo
tre anni fa ho iniziato a lavorare ad
amore il mio Brand di vestiti da
accessori un'impresa così impossibile
che al tempo mi sembrava solamente un
sogno una sola cosa ha fatto sì che
potesse diventare realtà
l'inconsapevolezza di quella ragazzina
alla costante ricerca di conferma
a vent'anni sto ancora aspettando Sto
benedetto conferme ma almeno ho capito
che va bene così
perché sfido qualsiasi persona da
mettere di non essersi mai sentito perso
senza uno scopo o alla ricerca di
qualcosa che poi che cos'è questo
qualcosa bene Io mi sento così da tutta
la vita in particolare da quando è
iniziata la mia adolescenza
e i social media purtroppo non hanno
aiutato
Perché i boomer ti dicono smettila di
guardare il telefono che poi ti viene
mal di testa almeno fosse mal di testa
Apri scrolli giù giù giù
like perché questo post ne ha più del
mio Io ricordo questa forte invidia
provata solamente su delle immagini e
dei numeri
e così inizi questa rincorsa qualcosa di
così inconsistente che porta a fare
delle cose assurde cioè io mi ricordo
ragazzi delle foto scattate Manco fossi
la cugina di quindicesimo grado di Kate
Moss e poi le cose un po' meno
divertenti perché arrivano anche i primi
disturbi
ansia sociale abuso di sostanze
dipendenze
disturbi del comportamento alimentare A
volte anche essi romanticizzati dalle
stesse piattaforme e tutti noi mossi
dalla stessa domanda ma come faccio ad
essere come loro come Queste persone che
vedo in queste immagini
bene alla Camilla di qualche anno fa che
si chiedeva se potesse mangiare le
briciole sulla tovaglia rispondo loro
non esistono e voi Mi direte Eh grazie e
faccia a dirsi ma non a farsi Lo so lo
so Ho dovuto fare un'azienda per
iniziare a capirlo
proprio così avevo talmente tanta voglia
di esprimere quello che avevo dentro la
mia rabbia le mie emozioni che non ho
aspettato mezzi per poterlo fare e mi
sono resa conto
che il modo che avevo per arrivare alle
persone Ce l'avevo in tasca tutti i
giorni della mia vita
quei maledetti Social
e ho iniziato a raccontarmi così No
All'inizio non è stato facile Ciao
ragazzi sono Camilla ho 17 anni sto
lanciando il mio Brand i vestiti da
accessori Oggi vi faccio vedere i miei
biglietti da visita non andavo a fare
visita a nessuno al sabato sera lo
stesso bar le stesse persone no vabbè
Cavolo ma io ti ho visto tutti che sto
qualcosa che vuoi fare ma stai facendo
Ma che carina
sotto i video Invece i primi commenti di
incoraggiamento che mi fanno capire di
starmi avvicinando sempre di più a una
nicchia di persone simili a me
quello che quello che doveva essere
solamente una grande distrazione Inizia
ad essere qualcosa di più concreto
e la domanda che mi viene fatta spesso
Eh sì è bello ma come hai fatto a
muovere i primi passi
il mondo della moda in Italia è un mondo
molto chiuso e purtroppo non ho
conoscenze quindi un giorno apro ricerca
Google
a fornitori maglieria in Italia Allora
il primo non lo prendiamo secondo una
div il terzo contattiamo un sabato
mattina mi faccio accompagnare da mio
papà che mi dice sì eh Va bene Ti
accompagno Ma che non sia un buco
nell'acqua
Tranquillo papà andiamo 3 ore di
macchina arriviamo a Carpi ci Apre
questa azienda un disastro un totale
disastro polvere scatoloni mi vengono
proposte delle cose inimmaginabili
usciamo mio papà
te l'avevo detto
lo sapevo noto però eravamo in un
complesso eravamo
in un complesso di stabili di diversi
magnifici noto però un'azienda a fianco
che mi sembrava aperta e io dico mio
papà Senti io provo a citofonare lui mi
dice Io ti aspetto in macchina
citofono voi immaginatevi cioè io avevo
17 anni Ma ormai mi sentivo una business
Woman giacca tacchetto vado valigetta
suono aprono No no non vogliamo niente
No Ma guardi Io sono Camillo 17 anni
ed è così che ho trovato il primo
fornitore di amore e da quel giorno mi
sono ripromessa di non perdere mai
quelli inappropriatezza che tanto aveva
distinto la mia adolescenza
e
così ho dovuto un po' trovare il mio
Balance anche nel raccontarmi perché io
ho iniziato ad immaginare queste
piattaforme come una bilancia da una
parte la mia vita il mio lavoro le
amicizie Gli amori ho sempre vent'anni e
dall'altra la mia immagine sui social
Ma perché Perché siamo nell'epoca della
volatilità dell'attimo della rincorsa e
non è facile non farsi ammaliare dai
numeri dai risultati dai voti belli o
brutti che siano ma costruire qualcosa
di duraturo È un processo lungo
lunghissimo
è l'unico modo per non farsi trascinare
in un turbine di ansie paure e andare a
recitare una realtà lo stesso meccanismo
adolescenziale poi
è raccontare di sé nel modo più genuino
possibile e far sì che questi due
aspetti siano sempre sullo stesso piano
perché volente una lente nella nostra
vita si andranno ad intrecciare
All'inizio ero anch'io alla ricerca di
un copione non mi sentivo abbastanza ma
quando ho capito che avevo con me il mio
bagaglio di errori di sbagli di successi
Allora ecco che tutti quei successi
insuccessi errori diventavano riflesso
di una nuova storia da raccontare
e quei giorni in cui mi sento giù dove
sbaglio dove mi arriva un campione
sbagliato cioè a volte mi arrivano delle
cose terribili ragazzi
completamente diverse diventano
immediatamente
una nuova storia
così le conferme tanto attese
che aspettavo ancora sto aspettando
le brutte figure i momenti no si mettono
sul mio stesso piano e finalmente faccio
pace con cui Maledetti paragoni
distruggendoci distruggendoli e
costruendoci sopra il lavoro più bello
del mondo creato da me per le persone
come me
oggi vi voglio lasciare anche io con una
frase Non so Mi hanno detto che di
solito si fa così quindi faccio anch'io
e
Siamo una generazione abbiamo sentito ne
abbiamo sentito anche oggi senza futuro
e qua crolla tutto Io credo che invece
abbiamo una quantità di mezzi che
nessuna generazione ha mai avuto e
possiamo veramente arrivare dove cavolo
vogliamo quindi il mio augurio è di
realizzare tutti quanti i vostri sogni
tranne uno perché Che cos'è la vita
senza un sogno